Megan margala said she never wants to
set foot in England again which is a
little awkward because her father-in-law
is the king of
England the only reason I care about
this story is not because I I do sort of
like the Royals I'm a little bit
anglophilic but they they can sort out
their own politics the the reason that I
care about this story is what it tells
you about marriage the the state of
modern marriage not just among
Aristocrats and nobility and royalty
overseas but among everyone right here
which is did she not think of this issue
before she married the prince did did
she not consider whether or not she
wanted to ever step foot in England
before she married uh the second most
notable prince of England you would
think that's the sort of thing you would
consider did she not recognize that when
she married a member of the royal family
a senior member of the royal family that
she might have some duties and
responsibilities that go along with that